decide your heading I want you to put
another word
which is a bit of weird voice probably
never met before at least not in a
mathematics of it because you don't ever
need to know what is cool
despite the fact you've actually been
doing it for quite the plan we're going
to do it today our continuation it's a
very unassuming title yeah here is very
simple you can start with an idea a very
simple concept and it works in like a
little area in mathematics and then we
think well what about outside that area
that we designed it for can we continue
that idea outside its original
definition so we actually do this very
very recently when we were doing
binomial here I introduced this guy what
I want you to go in this is the
factorial function write as an
exclamation right because it grows
really fast and we start with a
definition so it's right what was our
definition algebraically for n factorial
I'll give you a clue it starts with ends
welcome this n minus 1 and then 1 comes
out nice and moment and by now if you've
established the patterns if there is
you're going to go on to some amount I'm
doctor thought and has it in 3 2 1
so I'll just whisk so that everyone's
ready because why not
this is where we begin that photo
function and if you put in numbers by 5
or 10 or 100 if the haze just fine
right 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
inside cook this is what we call a
well-defined function it makes sense we
understand how it works however then I
post you this problem which initially
seems like sort of mathematical
curiosity but ended up being very very
important for us again hey that's it
right now the factorial function is
meant to be for positive numbers right 1
2 3 4 5 whole numbers as well so when
you look at this to like small it kind
of breaks this definition right it
starts after when it ends so we pulled
over a little bit but then we thought
another way if you think logically about
how all the factorials together we can
continue this continue it and find a
balance to the effect or applause of
course one very good one so we continue
so I'll just wait until everyone's ready
to close why not thank you
we continued a simple idea so somewhere
which is a bit unusual and we've been
doing this all throughout maps all the
way from kindergarten up to now you
start with a simple concept and then you
say hey you know how you can do this
right subtraction that's a simple idea
well more about this so we took the
natural number system the calculus and
we continue to we said well what about
over here and then we just can't use
this for that idea so what this is about
is that continuing the idea of sign
closet has outside of one of these right
this is where plain cotton pants begin
just like this is where and factorial
begins you can say so this angle over
here you can label or decide opposite
hypotenuse adjacent as long as your
angle is less than 93 stick in there and
you can come up with your definition for
sine theta plus Z unprotected okay but I
want to be able to do more than 90
degrees because there are lots of angles
in the world that are more than 90
degrees so that's what angles of any
magnitude means right not just limited
not just restricted to acute angle but
being able to look at any angle we like
okay so we introduced the shape and I
resist to yesterday do you remember and
you need to draw this with me if you
have a set of axes on the Cartesian
plane and if you draw themselves a nice
big circle one like circle
if your circle template on the origin
and you have a radius of 1 then we call
this guy's remember we called the unit
circle ready sorry you guys want to
finish outside it's important it's fine
you can talk about it elsewhere
I don't mind don't want to have to keep
on stopping so everyone can listen
that's all that's a serious question
neurotoxic do you want to be sure you
know go area okay
on me in a circle at some moment go time
okay but we can smuggle a right-angle
find in there and then we can continue
that you're here outside all angles that
are acute so let's come over triangle in
start the origin and just to make the
simple for us for spark in this quadrant
here one two three four but only numbers
are positive directly deposited to the
right the Y down is implanted in
particular so if you take a point like
that and you recognize and you have a
right angle in there and let's just
define the angle between the positive
x-axis and your radius we'll call that
guy feed on I've heard this is really
some belch okay if you do this sign
cousin's head up in that triangle right
remember this is the unit circle right
so what's the length of the hypotenuse
it's the radius which is one in this
case that I made a bigger circle right
why I got one
and just off to the side here you can
think about time and hand now in this
triangle because if the coordinates of
this are solar cell you someone else but
think about what sine signal would be
sine theta sine theta is opposite on
hypotenuse
you agree so this length on one
which is just this length right well
that's the y-coordinate do you agree
with that so it's the y-coordinates
divided by one in exactly the same way
if you think about clothes fit up
that's riche eyes that I can't do it
okay it's not hot is that another one
there right so I might draw that in
there you can to to complete the right
angle triangle and it's the adjacent
side so it's this on one right so in a
closed feed our ratio is going to be
that horizontal length on one which is
x1 so now you have look at those guys
right once you've got out as a
definition for x and y in terms of the
trig functions so instead of calling
this coordinate X comma Y I'm going to
call it
Kezia sine theta okay so if the X is an
alliance correspond to u cos and sine
then now I can actually get rid of this
triangle and it's still true right if I
change this angle fit up and like you
move it up
I follow you triangle but the coolness
is still going to be saying the lonely
thing about this is immediately tells
you where everything is on the circle
for it's a simple example let's go to
somewhere like here right on that pocket
okay what would you say to be at that
spot if I moved around the point until
it with kion you want to get a triangle
remember you want get a triangle because
figure is going to be when your dog
there zero exactly right remember it's
the angle between the positive x-axis
and or ever you put your radius if you
put your radius on the positive x-axis
there's no angle between ur so zero
right but that means I can understand
what conjurer and plan interior up cos 0
degrees sine 0 is you can't do these in
a triangle right you can't read it in a
triangle
but you can do it here what are the
coordinates of this spot
what's the excrement actually written by
romantic typing up one what's the white
one zero so when theta equals zero
you're spot-on in Cooper's good there
she had caused and his side cause the 0
is 1 and finally R is zero you can get
your calculator to convert that if you
like if you put in really really tiny
values all you set up like cause of zero
point zero zero zero zero or one or
something like that you'll go to
approach one but in writing the triangle
you can't actually get there right
because then your sides seem to did but
recycle can if every point on the
circumference has coordinates so
therefore it's got a computer and plug
it in exactly the same way let's take
the slide let's move him rather down
let's leave it up to here right what
would see the baby if I took the radius
and moves it around there it's going to
be 90 degrees right because it's between
the positive x-axis and I measure up
some 90 degrees doesn't fit inside and
right angle triangle right but it does
fit on the circle what are the
coordinates of this blue look we're
excited
yeah X X is going to be 0 and I've
already put the Y coordinates on this
now you told me enable with a 90 degree
so from here I can read that side there
is cause the cause of 90 degrees is zero
inches on the counter and sine of 90
degrees is going to be one and